سمر سالنا الناس خصوصا في مصر ما هي
الحرفه التي لم تختفي برايت نسمعهم ونرجع
[موسيقى]
النجاره تمام
من ايام سيدنا نوح يعني تقريبا قصه
السفينه دي اللي تذكرتها يعني دلوقتي
سيدنا نوح المنسوجات التطريز اا الحاجات
اللي هي التراث بتاعنا مثلا ممكن همم
حاجه زي النجاره مثلا
زي النقاشه دي الحرف اللي هما ما تنكرتش
ابدا في مصر عندنا
ليه لان الانسان هو اللي بيستخدم ايده
فيها لا ما اقدرش بقى لان لو في لا مصنع
ولا في اي حاجه
تبع يعني ايه همم الانسان يد الانسان هي
اللي بتصنع الحاجات دي اللي هي زي الترجي
ديت اللي هي بدله موظف حكومه هيبدا فاهم
لازم يلبس بدله موظف مدرسه بدله حلف مثلا
زي التصوير ده عباره عن فن فدلوقتي اي حد
ممكن عريس عروسه كده بيرجع
في الجواز في الفرح كده لازم يتصوروا في
الحلاق الكوافير وبتمدلله وحاجه الوحيده
اللي عمرها ما تنقرضت حتى ما فيش احد عمره
هيبطل طبعا
[موسيقى]